APRIL TWENTY EIGHTH ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
HEARING. WE HAVE A HUNDRED
EIGHTEEN BILLS TO CONSIDER THIS
MORNING BEFORE WE BEGIN I HAVE
A FEWHOUSEKEEPING NOTES TO
COVER FIRST OF ALL I'M GONNA
THINK- SOON AS THEY GET HERE
MISTER BLOOM MISTER KALRA AND I
SAW MISTER NAZARIAN FOR
COVERING VACANCIES AND THE
COMMITTEE TODAY. WHAT KEEPING A
PHYSICAL DISTANCE- BETWEEN ONE
ANOTHER IN THE HEARING ROOM AND
THREW OUT THE CAPITOL BUILDING
WE'RE ABLE TO HAVE ONLY NUMBER
LIMITED NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WATCHING PARTICIPATE WE ARE
ALSO REQUIREMENTS TO BE WORN
PLEASE WEAR THEM OR YOU WILL
BE- ASKED TO LEAVE THE-
BUILDING. WE'LL ACCEPT PUBLIC
COMMENT BEFORE THE CLOSE OF THE
HEARING TODAY THE CALL IN
NUMBER IS. 877-692-8957 IN THE
ACCESS CODE IS TWO FOUR TWO SIX
TWO THREE SEVEN THE CALL IN
INFORMATION IS ALSO AVAILABLE
AT THE DATE ON THE DAILY FILE
IN THE COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. IF
YOU HAVE PROBLEMS WITH THE
MODERATED PHONE SERVICE YOU MAY
CALL THE COMMITTEE OR AT THREE
ONE NINE TWO ZERO EIGHT ONE
THAT'S NINE ONE SIX AND MY
STAFF WILL TRY TO HELP ALSO
NOTE THAT WE ACCEPT WRITTEN
TESTIMONY THROUGH THE
COMMITTEES EMAIL SYSTEM AND
THROUGH THE POSTAL SERVICE AS
DESCRIBED IN THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. THANK YOU
FOR BEARING WITH US TODAY ONE
MORE- REMINDER THAT IF YOU'RE
CALLING INTO YOUR NOT ABIDING
BY OUR VERY CLEAR VERY BRIEF
RULES- WE WILL NOT ALLOW YOU TO
SPEAK AND- THAT MEANS THAT IF
YOU'RE WHEN AS YOU GET TO SPEAK
FOR TWO MINUTES ONLY TWO
MINUTES. ON THE PHYSICAL ASPECT
OF THE BILL IN NOTHING ELSE A
ONE WITNESS ON EACH SIDE OF THE
MAX WE WILL HAVE AND THEN AFTER
THAT WE ARE ONLY ALLOWING YOUR
NAME YOUR ORGANIZATION AND YOUR
POSITION ON A BILL IF YOU
DEVIATE FROM THAT WE WILL
DISCONNECT YOUR PHONE SO I WANT
PEOPLE TO BE CLEAR. DO NOT
CALLING DEVIATE FROM THAT WE
WILL NOT HEAR YOU ALSO PLEASE
DO NOT CALL IN ON THE WRONG
BILL PLEASE LISTEN TO THE BILL
THAT I WERE TAKING A SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION TO AND THAT'S WHAT
WE EXPECT TO HEAR. ON THE PHONE
AT THAT TIME. BEFORE WE BEGIN
WE ARE GOING TO BEGIN AS A SUB
COMMITTEE L. AS SUBCOMMITTEE.
WE HAVE QUORUM- I'M SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. GONZALEZ
PRESENT BIGELOW CALDERON.
CARRILLO CHAU DOLLY DAVIES FONG
GABBRO WATER GARCIA LIVING WORK
ROBERT RIVAS KALRA THE VARIANT.
BOOM. THANK YOU THERE'S A
QUORUM PRESENT- BEFORE WE BEGIN
TODAY- I AM GOING TO TAKE A
MOMENT IF IT'S OKAY IT IS DENIM
DAY AND I KNOW THIS IS LIKE THE
SECOND TIME WE'VE CELEBRATE
DENIM DAY IN IN THE- BUILDING
AND THAT'S AN IMPORTANT DAY.
TODAY'S
A TODAY WE CELEBRATE WORKERS
WHO LOST THEIR LIVES- IN THEIR
JOB. AND IT'S ALWAYS TRAGIC
EVERY YEAR RIGHT OCCUPATIONAL
HAZARDS INDUSTRIAL ACCIDENTS
AND- SO OFTEN UNNECESSARY
DOUBTS BUT THIS YEAR IS
EXTREMELY- CRITICAL BECAUSE SO
MANY WORKERS DIED ON THE JOB OF
COBIT EXPOSURE IN GUN VIOLENCE
HONESTLY AND SO IF IT'S OKAY
I'D ASK PEOPLE TO TAKE A MOMENT
OF SILENCE TO HONOR THE WORKERS
WHO. LOST JUST DOING THEIR JOB.
THANK YOU FOR THAT- WE WILL NOW
PROCEED IN ORDER OF AUTHORS AS
I SAW THEM- I SAW IT I WALKED
IN FACT WITH MR BONTA SO WE
WILL BEGAN WITH HER AT. AB
SEVEN SIXTY FOUR ENJOY THE DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION I HAVE A
MOTION BY MISTER CALDERON A
SECOND BY. MISTER BIGELOW.
PLEASE PROCEED THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS FOR ALLOWING
ME TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVENTY SIX FOR TODAY THE
PURPOSE OF THIS BILLS TO HELP
UPDATE OUR STATE'S CRIMINAL LAW
TO REFLECT THE REALITIES OF THE
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY UNDER
CURRENT LAW OUR COURTS CAN
ISSUE PROTECTIVE ORDERS AGAINST
PERPETRATORS WHO HAVE BEEN
CONVICTED OF STALKING THERE ARE
CRIMINAL PENALTIES FOR
PERPETRATORS TO CONTACT A
SURVIVOR DIRECTLY BY TELEPHONE
OR BY USING PHYSICAL MAIL IN
VIOLATION OF A PROTECTIVE
ORDER. HOWEVER THE REALITIES OF
OUR MARTYRED MODERN WORLD IS
THAT IS INCREASINGLY LIKELY FOR
STOCKING TRICKER OVER SOCIAL
MEDIA OR THE INTERNET I THISIS
BEEN ESPECIALLY TRUE DURING THE
PANDEMIC PUBLIC HEALTH MEASURES
LIKE STAFF HOME ORDERS AND
SOCIAL ISTANCING HAD MADE HER
ASPEN OVER SOCIAL MEDIA ONLY
MORE PREVALENT UNFORTUNATELY
GIVEN THE CURRENT CONSTRUCTION
OF THE LAW A CONVICTED STALKER
STALKER MAY GO UNPUNISHED FOR
CONTACTING A SURVIVOR USING
SOCIAL MEDIA OR THE INTERNET
EVEN IF A PROTECTIVE ORDER IS
IN PLACE AGAINST THEM. ASSEMBLY
BILL SEVEN SIX FOUR WE'LL CLOSE
THIS LOOPHOLE BY ADDING CONTACT
OVER SOCIAL MEDIA OR OTHER
ELECTRONIC MEANS TO THE LIST OF
PROHIBITED FORMS OF ACTIVITY
THIS WILL NOT ONLY UPDATE THE
LAW TO REFLECT INTERNET AGE BUT
ALSO PROVIDE SURVIVORS WITH
MORE PROTECTION ESPECIALLY
DURING THE COURSE OF THIS
PANDEMIC. WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL IS PASSED
SB NO STOCK REPRESENTING SAN
DIEGO COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY.
SUMMER STEPHAN THE SPONSOR OF
THE BILL. WE ALREADY HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND- AT MISTER
ROGERS I DON'T HAVE A WITNESS
LISTED FOR YOU- SO IT MAY NOT
BE IN THE QUEUE. WE DON'T NEED
ONE EITHER SO I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE MATTER YOU
HAVE A BIPARTISAN A MOTION AND
A SECOND WITH THAT WE WILL OPEN
UP THE PHONE LINES- WE WILL
OPEN UP THE PHONE LINES.
OPERATOR TO ANYONE WHO WANTS TO
REGISTER ONLY THEIR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION THEIR NAME THEIR
POSITION IN THE ORGANIZATION
FOR AB SEVEN SIXTY FOUR. THANK
YOU TO STATE YOUR POSITION ON
A. B. SEVEN SIXTY FOUR PLEASE
PRESS ONE MIN MISSOURI. THAT'S
ONE ZERO USING YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD. WE'LL GO FIRST TO LINE
FORTY SIX FOUR SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. SIX PLEASE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BERMAN BONTA LINE FORTY
EIGHT FOUR EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ONE MOMENT. FORTY EIGHT
PLEASE AGAIN. THIS IS PATRICK
ESPINOZA I'M THE DIVISION CHIEF
THIS ANNUAL COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE SEX CRIMES
AND HUMAN TRAFFICKING DIVISION
AND WE'RE CALLING IN SUPPORT OF
AB SEVEN SIXTY FOUR. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANK MANAGER NO
FURTHER LINES IN QUEUE FOR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU WILL BRING
THAT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE SEEN
NO COMMENT. THAT GETS OUT ON A
ROLL CALL THANK YOU MISTER
ROGERS THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
MYSTERY OF US. MISS REAVIS
ENJOYS A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION.
ON AB FIFTEEN FIFTY I SEE A
MOTION BY A DOCTOR QUIRK. AND A
SECOND BY MISTER BLOOM. ALL
RIGHT MISS REAVIS GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS AB
FIFTEEN FIFTY PROTECTS FACULTY
BARGAINING RIGHTS BY ALLOWING
FACULTY WHO ARE CURRENTLY IN A
BARGAINING UNIT TO REMAIN
ELIGIBLE FOR UNION
REPRESENTATION EVEN IF THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA MOVES
THOSE FACULTY POSITIONS. IN THE
ACADEMIC SENATE. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU WE WILLNOW GO TO THE
PHONE LINES YOU HAVE NO
WITNESSES SO WE'LL GO STRAIGHT
TO SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION.AB
FIFTEEN FIFTY IF THERE'S
ANYBODY IN SUPPORT WANT TO
REGISTER THEIR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OPERATOR. THANK YOU
TO STATE YOUR POSITION EITHER
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION FOR AB
FIFTEEN FIFTY PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. AGAIN THAT'S
A ONE AND THEN ZERO ON YOUR
PHONE. WELL FIRST ONLINE TWENTY
EIGHT TO EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. LET ME CENTERS ON BEHALF
OF AT THE ARE YOU CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NEXT WE
HAVE LINE. FIFTY FOUR FIVE
FOUR. YES MY NAME IS HELEN
BOWDEN I TEACH ANTHROPOLOGY
AMERICAN RIVER COLLEGE AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB ONE SIX
NINE THANK YOU THANK YOU. NEXT
WE HAVE LINE. FIFTY THREE FIVE
THREE. FIFTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN HER AB. FIFTEEN FIFTY. HI
THIS IS MIKE WHEELER CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS WERE ONE
OF THE SPONSORS OF THE BILL
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU. WHAT
ONLINE SIXTEEN ONE SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS MY NAME PROBABLY ON
YOUNG FORMER BOILED WILL BOARD
MEMBER- IN STRONG SUPPORT THE
BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU. WHEN
LINE SIXTY SIX ZERO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. NINE SIXTEEN YOU MAY
BE I MEAN. AT THIS TIME I'M
SURE THERE ARE NO FOR THE LINES
IN Q. SO THAT WAS BOTH SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION I WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE I SEE NO
QUESTIONS WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE WE'RE GONNA PUT THAT ON
HOLD UNTIL WE GET MORE
DEMOCRATS DOWN ON THIS
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU. NEXT I
SEE MR JONES SAWYER MISTER
JOINED SAWYER- IS PRESENTING IT
AB TEN FORTY TWO AND ENJOYS A
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION. I SEE A
MOTION BY MISTER NAZARIAN AND A
SECOND BY DOCTOR CORK. YOU MAY
PROCEED THANK YOU GOOD MORNING
JERRY MEMBERS I'M PRESENTING AB
TEN FORTY TO MAKE SURE NO
COMPANY CAN ESCAPE THE
CONSEQUENCES OF PROVIDING SUB
STANDARD CARE TO OUR MOST
VULNERABLE CALIFORNIA'S.
SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL WILL
ALLOW THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
TO BROADEN THE SCOPE AND SEE
PAYMENT FOR UNPAID NURSING HOME
VIOLATION FROM AFFILIATED
BUSINESSES OWNED. OR CONTROLLED
BY THE LICENSEE OF THE SKILLED
FACILITY AS OF FEBRUARY TWENTY
FIRST- IS NOW STANDING FIVE
POINT EIGHT MILLION IN UNPAID
CITATIONS THAT NURSING
FACILITIES THAT FAIL TO PAY.
FOR QUALITY CARE- AB MEMBERS
THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN ASSEMBLY
HEALTH COMMITTEE. WITH ME TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL IS
TIFFANY WHITE WITH S. E. I. U.
THANK YOU ARE VERY CAN WE GO TO
THE WITNESS LINE. THE LINE IS
OPEN THE MAIN PROCEEDS. GIVE ME
LIKE LOOK AT THE ARE YOU
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE A LOT OF THE
TWENTY THOUSAND NURSING
FACILITY EMPLOYEES TALKED ABOUT
MAYBE TEN THIRTY TO BECOME.
LIABILITY FROM OWNERS OF THE
NATIVE PARTY AFTER NURSING
FACILITY ARE GIVEN A NOTED ONE
PER OF THE TIME PRICE TAG
AFFECT FOR PICTURE WHAT I'M-
BUT YOU COULD BUY POINT EIGHT
MORE OUT. IN ADDITION THE
COLLAPSE OF THE QUAL IS CRUCIAL
BECAUSE OF DOWN NEEDED FEDERAL
MEDICAID BY FOR THE- SO FORTY
BIG VOICE TO THE STATE BY. AND
THEIR FOR THE RESIDENTS AND
WORKERS WITH RESPECT REQUEST I
THOUGHT. THANK YOU GO TO THE
LINES. FOR TO REGISTER THEIR-
ON. TO A TEN FORTY TWO. THANK
YOU STATE YOUR PER WHETHER SUB
OR A- TO AB TERM FOR TWO THIS
PRESS ONE ON ZERO ON YOUR
PHONE. THAT'S ONE BEEN THERE ON
YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD. WE HAVE
NO LINES IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE I SEE NO COMMENT.
MISTER JONES SAWYER WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL WE'RE GONNA PUT THAT
ON CALL UNTIL HE GETS MORE
FOLKS DOWN HERE BUT THANK YOU.
IRATE I SEE NO AUTHORS THAT'S
NOT A GOOD SIGN- MISTER
NAZARIAN GO HEAD. WE WILL START
TO GO TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
MISTER NAZARIAN. IT IS GOING TO
PRESENT ON AB TWELVE SEVENTY
EIGHT ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION- I SEE A MOTION
BY MISS CARILLO I SEE A SECOND
BY DOCTOR QUIRK THANK YOU.
MISTER NAZARIAN YOU MAY PROCEED
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS- I'LL BEGIN FIRST OF
ALL BY ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS WHICH AMONG OTHERS
OTHER ITEMS WILL DELETE THE
REQUIREMENT OF AN ORAL
DISCLOSURE- AB TWELVE SEVENTY
TO SIMPLY PUT WOULD REQUIRE
PHYSICIANS AND SURGEONS WHO
RECEIVE PAYMENTS FROM A DRUG OR
DEVICE COMPANY TO DISCLOSE
THOSE RELATIONSHIPS IN WRITING.
TO EACH PATIENT PRIOR TO
TREATMENT THE DISCLOSURE-
SYSTEM OF ALREADY EXISTS- AND
IT JUST WOULD REQUIRE THE
DOCTOR'S OFFICE TO POINT OUT TO
THE FEDERAL OPEN PAYMENTS
WEBSITE AND FOR A PATIENT TO
PROVIDE A SIGNATURE. HAPPY TO
TAKE ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
WE WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINES-
AB TWELVE SEVENTY EIGHT THERE
ARE NO WITNESSES LISTED SO WE
WILL GO STRAIGHT TO SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. SHARE YOUR POSITION
EITHER SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
FOR AB TWELVE SEVENTY EIGHT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN THEY'RE
ON THE PHONE ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO AT THIS TIME PLEASE. WELL
THE FIRST ON LINE SEVENTEEN ONE
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SH
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR TO MADDEN
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
pOF CARDIOLOGY THE CALIFORNIA
RHEUMATOLOGY ALLIANCE IN THE
CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF PLASTIC.
CAL FREE SOCIETY OF PLASTIC
SURGEONS IN OPPOSITION. KIM
NEXT WE HAVE ONLINE SEVENTY TWO
SEVEN TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING REBECCA MARKETS ON
BEHALF OF THE SPONSORS THE
CENTER FOR PUBLIC INTEREST LAW
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
AND WE HAVE NO FOR THE LANSING
CARE AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
OPERATOR WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE MISTER NAZARIAN.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE
THANK YOU. WE WILL PUT THAT ON
CALL I THINK WE'RE WAITING ON
ONE MORE. PERSON TO COME THANK
YOU MISTER NAZARIAN. NEXT I SAW
COMMEND MR RODRIGUEZ AND THEN
AFTER THAT WILL BE MISTER
FRAZIER AND THE METS FRIEDMAN-
MISTER RODRIGUEZ. AB EIGHT
FORTY FIVE ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION I SEE A MOTION
BY A DOCTOR QUIRK AND A SECOND
BY MISTER CALDERON YOU MAY
PROCEED. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS A. B. A. FORTY FIVE
WILL CREATE A TEMPORARY
REBUTTABLE PRESUMPTION FOR FROM
MY WORKERS THAT A COVERT
NINETEEN RELATED ILLNESS
CONTRACTED ON THE JOB SHALL BE
ELIGIBLE FOR IN SERVICE
DISABILITY RETIREMENT THIS FROM
MY WORKERS INCLUDE HEALTHCARE
PROVIDERS FIREFIGHTERS LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND PUBLIC SERVANTS
TO NAME A FEW. CALLING IN
TODAY'S TEN REDDIT REPRESENTING
SEIU THE SPONSOR TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT AND RESPOND ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU WILL GO TO
THE WITNESS- IF THEY WOULD LIKE
TO JUST EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT
THAT WOULD BE GREAT STARTING
WITH THE WITNESSES I THINK
TERRY BRENNAN FROM THIS AREA.
OPERATOR TO GO TO THE PHONE
THANK YOU IF. YOU LIKE TO STATE
YOUR POSITION ON THIS BILL AB
EIGHT. FORTY FIVE PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. SEVERAL LINES IN QB JUST
A MOMENT PLEASE. THE FIRST ON
LINE SIXTY EIGHT SIX EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. COKER WITH THE
AMERICAN FEDERATION OF STATE
COUNTY AND MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT
FORTY FIVE. THANK YOU NEXT WE
HAVE LINE SIXTY SIXTY THREE SIX
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU THIS IS INTERTWINED WITH
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC EMPLOYEES
RETIREMENT SYSTEM IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. ONLINE SEVENTY NINE
SEVEN NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS BRANDON UP
ON BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. LINE.
TWENTY EIGHT TO EIGHT. LINE.
TWENTY ONE. ON BEHALF OF AT THE
ARE YOU CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT
THANK YOU. NO FOR THE LINE
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU I HAVE LISTED- CHRISTY BAMA
FROM THE CALIFORNIA
ROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS AS
WELL WE'LL JUST REGISTER HER
SUPPORT AND SHE WAS LISTED AS A
WITNESS- WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE MISTER RODRIGUEZ.
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL THANK
YOU AND THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL
CALL WITH MISS DOLLY IN MR FONG
NOT VOTING THANK YOU. M. AS
LONG AS WE ARE HERE WE CAN NOW
SAY THAT AB FIFTEEN FIFTY GOT
OFF ON A B. ROLL CALL AB TEN
FORTY TWO GOT OFF ON A B. ROLL
CALL AB TWELVE SEVENTY EIGHT
GOT OFF. WITH REPUBLICANS NOT
VOTING. THANK YOU WE WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO MISTER FRAZIER. MR
FRAZIER- AB NINE OH THREE
ENJOYS A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
OF A MOTION BY MISTER BIGELOW
IN A SECOND- BY MISTAKE THESE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
COLLEAGUES. AS ALL OF YOU KNOW
THE CODE NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS
EXPOSED CRITICAL SHORTFALLS IN
HEALTH CARE AND HEALTH SERVICES
FUNDING ACROSS THE STATE.
HUMANITY IS OF COLOR HAVE BEEN
ESPECIALLY IMPACTED BY THE
EMERGENCY. NOW MORE THAN EVER
WE HAVE SEEN THE LIFE CHANGING
IMPACTS OF THE VOTING EVERY
POSSIBLE DOLLAR TO SERVING
THOSE WHO WE REALLY REPRESENT.
AB NANO THREE IS A DISTRICT
BILL TO TAKE STRIDES TOWARD
ADDRESSING THIS ISSUE. THE BILL
EFFECTIVELY CREATE HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS IN FUNDING
FOR BADLY NEEDED HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. IN THE REGION. AB
NINE OH THREE IS A GOOD
GOVERNMENT BILLS. THE CARD
ACOSTA LEFT WHO HAS APPROVED OF
THE DISSOLUTION OF THE EXISTING
HEALTH CARE DISTRICT AND THE
COUNTY ALREADY SERVES THE
COMMUNITIES WITHIN THE DISTRICT
BOUNDARIES. THIS DEVOLUTION WAS
PARTLY APPROVED DUE TO THE
DISTRICTS HIDE MINISTRY OF
EXPENSES WHICH TO TALK 260% IN
SOME YEARS. COMPATIBLE PROGRAMS
OF THE COUNTY RIGHT 15220% AND
I NEARBY HEALTH CARE DISTRICT
RUNS CLOSE 220% ALSO. RATHER
THAN LOSE OVER HALF THE FUNDING
TO WASTEFUL ADMINISTRATIVE
EXPENSES EIGHTY NINE OH THREE
IS DEDICATED THOSE DOLLARS TO
THE COMMUNITY. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL. THANK YOU COPY RIGHT
WHEN I WAS DRINKING MY COFFEE.
AB. EIGHT OH THREE WE WILL GO
IS NO WITNESS LISTED SO JUST
SPEAKERS AND SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO IT AB EIGHT OH
THREE. NINE OH THREE SORRY I
KNOW THREE. AS PER MY PREVIOUS
STATE YOUR POSITION NOT EITHER
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OVER THE
PHONE AB NINE OLD THREE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO GAME OF
TELEPHONE COMMANDERS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. WE DO HAVE A FEW
LINES IN QUEUE FOR THIS BILL BE
JUST A MOMENT. WE'LL GO FIRST
TO LINE EIGHTY EIGHT ZERO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
KAREN MEMBERS BATTLING COOPER
FROM NIELSEN MARKS WERE ON
BEHALF OF CONTRA COSTA COUNTY
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NEXT WE HAVE LINE THIRTY FOUR
THREE FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YES MY NAME IS GREY GOES SO
PRESIDENT OF THE NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION SOLDIERS AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE WE DO. EIGHTY
NINE OH THREE THANK YOU. NEXT
WE HAVE A LINE THIRTY FIVE
THREE FIVE. HELLO MARK FOR
MAYOR OF THE LARGEST CITY IN
THE THAT YOU CAN CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY AND EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF DEMONSTRATE STRONGLY ABOUT.
THANK YOU. WE HAVE ONLINE
SEVENTY SEVEN ZERO.
CALIFORNIA'S RESIDENT OF
PITTSBURGH IN OPPOSITION.
EIGHTY NINE OH THREE. THANK YOU
NEXT WE HAVE A LINE FORTY THREE
FOUR THREE. SHOULD CLEAR COMMON
LAWSUIT HONEST DISTRICT IN
OPPOSITION EIGHTY NINE OF.
THREE THANK YOUNG WE HAVE LINE
EIGHTY ONE EIGHT ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. YEARNING FOR COSMIC
REALITY PHD I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
EIGHTY NINE OH THREE. THANK YOU
WE HAVE A WE HAVE A LINE EIGHTY
EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. EDITION MARCH. BORDER
DIRECTOR FOR LOVE ABOUT TWENTY
HEALTHCARE DISTRICT STRONGLY
OPPOSE. THANK YOU. NINE THIRTY
TWO THREE TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THEN THE STRONG ORDER DIRECTORS
WILL LOVE MADONNA COMMUNITY
HEALTH CARE DISTRICT I STRONGLY
OPPOSE AB EIGHT NINE OH THREE.
THANK YOUNG. M. SIXTY NINE SIX
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AFTER A
LOT OF BAD ANTIOCH RESIDENT
CALLING IN OPPOSITION AB NINE
OF THREE. THANK YOU. NINE
SEVENTY ONE SEVEN ONE YOUR MIND
IS OPEN. NAME IS ALAN DAILY BUT
IT'S IN THE NELLIE'S KARATEDO
STANLEY- AB NINE OH THREE.
THANK YOU. NINE EIGHTY SEVEN
EIGHT SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
DOT ONE ZERO PITTSBURGH
STRONGLY OPPOSE. EIGHTY NINE
ZERO THREE. NEXT WE HAVE LINE
NINETY ONE NINE ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. IN BREAKING WITH THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
HEALTHCARE DISTRICT CANNOT
PROFICIENCY. THANK YOU. M. LINE
NINETY THREE NINE THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. RHONDA BURKE
COMMUNITY MEMBER STRONGLY
OPPOSED. EIGHTY NINE OH THREE.
AT THIS TIME WE HAVE NO FURTHER
LINES IN Q. THANK YOU I BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I SEE NO QUESTIONS THAT
GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL THANK
YOU MISTER FRAZIER VERY MUCH
MENTOR. THANK YOU MISS FRIEDMAN
LOOKS LIKE YOU HAVE TO BILLS
YOU'RE PRESENTING TODAY THE
FIRST IS. AB SIX SEVENTY NINE-
THAT ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION I HAVE A MOTION
BY MISCREANTS- A SECOND BY.
MISTER CALDERON YOU MAY PROCEED
GOOD MORNING TEARING MEMBERS IN
CUSTODY INFORMANTS ARE PROVEN
TO BE A SIGNIFICANT. CAUSE OF
WRONGFUL CONVICTIONS SINCE
NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE EUROPEAN
TWO HUNDRED EIGHTEEN KNOWN
EXONERATIONS IN CALIFORNIA. OF
THESE TWO HUNDRED EIGHTEEN
CASES NINETEEN INVOLVED THE
FALSE CLAIMS OF JAIL HOUSE
INFORMANTS. EIGHTEEN OF THESE
INDIVIDUALS ARE SERVING IFE
SENTENCES AND COLLECTIVELY
THESE MEN AND WOMEN SPENT THREE
HUNDRED AND FIVE YEARS
WRONGFULLY INCARCERATED. THE
USE OF INTENSITY INFORMANTS IN
CRIMINAL PROSECUTIONS HAS BEEN
A LONG TIME INVESTIGATIVE COOL
BY LAW ENFORCEMENT. DESPITE
NUMEROUS SCANDALS REVEALING THE
CONSTITUTIONAL IMPLICATIONS OF
THE USE OF INFORMANTS AND THEIR
APPARENT ABILITY TO LIFE THE
PRACTICE CONTINUES. LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFER BENEFITS IN
RETURN FOR PROVIDING
INFORMATION INCENTIVIZE THOSE
IN CUSTODY TO FABRICATE
TESTIMONY IN EXCHANGE FOR THESE
BENEFITS. I JUST IN OUR LAST
HEARING OUR COLLEAGUE REBECCA
BARRICADE HAND DESCRIBED A CASE
THAT SHE HAD WORKED ON
PERSONALLY FOR A MAN WHO WAS ON
DEATH ROW. DUE TO BE EXECUTED
HI THIS CASE EXONERATED BY HER
AND A TEAM WORKING PRO BONO AND
DISCOVERED THAT HE WAS
WRONGFULLY CONVICTED WRONGFULLY
CONVICTED BASED ON A LINE JAIL
HOUSE INFORMANT. LAST YEAR
JUSTICE COURT IN LIEU OF THE
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT CALLED
UPON THE LEGISLATURE DO
SOMETHING ABOUT LAW
ENFORCEMENTS USE OF INCIDENTS
INCENTIVIZE INFORMANTS BECAUSE
OF THE PRACTICES THREAT TO
CONSTITUTIONAL PROTECTIONS AND
PUBLIC SAFETY. AND TO BE CLEAR
LAW ENFORCEMENT CAN STILL USE
THESE WITNESSES TO PROVIDE A
TESTIMONY AND EVIDENCE THE BILL
DOES NOT ALLOW THEM TO BE PUT
ON THE WITNESS STAND BUT THEY
CAN STILL TAKE THEIR TESTIMONY
AND GO INVESTIGATE AND GATHER
EVIDENCE. SB SIX SEVENTY NINE
AND THIS PRACTICE TO PROTECT
THE INNOCENT AND WITH THAT I
AND I CONTINUE TO WORK LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO ADDRESS THEIR
CONCERNS AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU
THANK YOU I'M GOING TO REPLACE
THAT MOTION AND SECOND AND I'M
SORRY I JUMPED THE GUN ON THAT-
THAT WAS A MOTION BY MISS
CARILLO THAT WAS THE SECOND BY
MISTER KALRA- WITH THAT WE WILL
GO TO THE LINE. TO THE PHONE
LINES AB SIX SEVENTY NINE. JUST
REGISTRY. IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. STATE YOUR POSITION
EITHER SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO
AB SIX SEVENTY NINE HIS PRESS
ALONG THE MEMBERS ARE ALL ON
YOUR PHONE. THAT'S ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD. WE DO HAVE A FEW LINES
IN Q. ONE MOMENT PLEASE. FIRST
OVER THE LINE FORTY ONE FOUR
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING MELISSA O'CONNELL FROM
THE NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
INNOCENCE PROJECT REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA AND ITS AND
COALITION WE ARE PROUD CO
SPONSOR OF EIGHTY SIX SEVEN
NINE THANK YOU. NEXT WE HAVE
LINE ONE OH FIVE ONE OH FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
IGNACIO HERNANDEZ ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE WE ARE ALSO
PROUD CO SPONSOR. THANK YOU
KNOW FOR THE LINE THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU AS WE WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
C. NO COMMENT- MISREAD MY WE'RE
GONNA PUT THAT ON CALL UNTIL WE
GET ONE MORE. PERSON DOWN HERE
AND HOPEFULLY MISTER RIVAS
MISTER GARCIA- CAN. JUST COME.
AT WITHOUT WE WILL GO ON TODAY
AB EIGHT THIRTY EIGHT ENJOYS A
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION WE HAVE
A MOTION BY MISTER CALDERON IN
A SECOND BY MISS CARILLO THANK
YOU- CHECK MISS MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS HOUSING BUILDING CODES
ARE NEEDED TO ENSURE THAT
RESIDENTS ARE SAFE IN THEIR
DRAWINGS BUT UNFORTUNATELY IN
CALIFORNIA SOME CITIES PUT PRE
CONDITIONS ON TENANTS ABILITIES
TO MAKE THESE- HABITABILITY
COMPLAINTS THIS SOMETIMES
RESULTS IN OUR MOST VULNERABLE
RESIDENTS BEING AFRAID TO GO TO
ARE BEING NOT HEARD WHEN THEY
TRY TO RAISE SERIOUS ISSUES
ABOUT HAVE ABILITY IN THEIR- OF
PLACES OF DWELLING. MEMBERS
THIS BILL WAS SPAWNED BY AN L.
I. L. A. S. ARTICLE THAT I READ
THAT TALKED ABOUT THE DEATHS OF
CHILDREN IN A SLUM TYPE
DWELLING WHERE THE. YEAR AFTER
YEAR AFTER YEAR FORCING THEM TO
PUT SPACE HEATERS AND OTHER
UNSAFE DEVICES IN THEIR
APARTMENT JUST TO KEEP THEIR
CHILDREN WARM THIS LED TO THE
DEATH OF SEVERAL INDIVIDUALS
INCLUDING CHILDREN CITY SHOULD
ALWAYS HAVE THE RESPONSIBILITY
OF MAKING SURE THAT THE
APARTMENTS ARE SAFE WITH THAT I
REQUEST WE REQUEST AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS
FRIEDMAN WITH THAT WE WILL GO
TO THE PHONE LINES ON AB. EIGHT
THIRTY EIGHT. SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. YOU TO STATE YOUR
POSITION AN AIM BE EIGHT THIRTY
WILL EITHER SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION YOU MAY PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AGAIN ON YOUR
PHONE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. LOCAL FIRST
ONLINE FIFTEEN ONE FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS- CREAM
GREASY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS IN OPPOSITION WITH AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU.
NEXT WE HAVE LINE EIGHTY THREE
EIGHTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THE MORNING CARE MEMBERS RIGHT
I GOT THAT ON BEHALF OF A
CALIFORNIA ROLL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION AND
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY- PRADA CONSTRUCTOR THIS
MEASURE. THANK YOU. IN ORDER
LINE THANK YOU AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU WITH THAT WILL BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE I SEE
NO QUESTIONS WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE THANK YOU MISS FRIEDMAN
THAT GETS OUT ON A OF THE ROLL
CALL. THANK YOU MR BERMAN I
GUESS YOUR NEXT. AB TWO THIRTY
SIX ENJOY THE DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION AT WE HAVE A
MOTION BY MISTER CALDERON A
SECOND BY MISS CARILLO YOU MAY
PROCEED THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
THAT EXCITED INTRODUCTION MADAM
CHAIR- AND COLLEAGUES AB TWO
THIRTY SIX WHICH IS SPONSORED
BY THE FAIR POLITICAL PRACTICES
COMMISSION SIMPLY ENSURE THAT
LIMITED LIABILITY COMPANIES
ALSO KNOWN AS LLCS THAT MAKE
CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTIONS AND
EXPENDITURES MUST PUBLICLY
DISCLOSE SPECIFIED MEMBERS OF
THE L. C. FOR THAT VOTERS HAVE
INFORMATION ABOUT THE TRUE
SOURCE OF FUNDS. USED BY ALL
SEASON STATE ELECTIONS THIS
BILL WILL HELP ENSURE THE L. C.
DON'T BECOME THE NEW PREFERRED
VENUE FOR DARK MONEY CALIFORNIA
ELECTIONS THIS BILL PROPOSES A
BALANCED APPROACH THAT ENSURES
TRANSPARENCY WHILE AVOIDING
OVERLY BURDENSOME REQUIREMENTS
ACCORDINGLY THE FISCAL EFFECT
IS EXPECTED TO BE MODEST THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MR BERMAN AND
WE WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINES
ARE THERE- SUPPORTERS OR-
PEOPLE IN OPPOSITION TO AB TWO
THIRTY SIX. TO STATE YOUR
POSITION ON AB TWO THIRTY SIX
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN THE
ZERO. I WON FOLLOWED BY ZERO ON
YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD. NO LINES
INTO AT THIS TIME. LOOK AT THAT
MR BERMAN I DON'T WANT YOUR
CLOTHES YOU GOTTA BE ROLL CALL
MOVE ON SEARCH ENGINE THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT. AS I A CAN ANNOUNCE
THAT- AB SIX SEVENTY NINE BY MS
FREEMAN GETS OUT ON THE B. ROLL
CALL WITH MISS COLOR I'M NOT
VOTING. WE WILL NOW MOVE ON. TO
IS MR SHOWERS HERE YES WE WILL
TAKE MISTER CHILD- AB. THIRTY
NINE. IT ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION OF A MOTION BY
MISS CARILLO IN A SECOND BY
MISS CALDERON YES I DO ALL
RIGHT MISTER CHOW GO AHEAD
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MEANT-
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS AB
THIRTY NINE WOULD CODIFY AND
RECOGNIZE CALIFORNIA CHINA
CLIMATE INSTITUTE. TO
ACCELERATE CLIMATE ACTION
THROUGH ALL COOPERATION AND
EXCHANGES BETWEEN TWO OF THE
WORLD'S MAJOR EMITTERS OF
GREENHOUSE GASES NAMELY
CALIFORNIA AND CHINA THE BILL
WOULD HAVE MINOR AND ABSORB
WILL COST TO THE UC ESTY
INSTITUTE IS CURRENTLY FUNDED
WITHOUT FELON ON TOPIC OF FUNDS
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR. YOUR
VOTE. THANK YOU WE WILL GO
AHEAD AND GO TO THE PHONE LINES
AB THIRTY NINE SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION. YOUR POSITION FOR
AMY THIRTY NINE PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. USING
YOUR TELEPHONE PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO FOR A. B. THIRTY
NINE. THERE ARE NO LINES IN Q.
THANK YOU BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ARE THERE QUESTIONS
THERE ARE NO QUESTIONS MR CAL
YOUR CLOTHES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL I GET TIRED ON A B. ROLL
CALL WITH MR FONG NOT VOTING TO
MR LEVINE VOTING NO. WITH THAT
WE WILL MOVE ON TO AB FOURTEEN
NINETY TWO MISTER CHILD THANK
YOU AGAIN MAIENSCHEIN MELENDEZ
JOYS EIGHTY OF MOTION BY MISTER
CALDERON A SECOND BY MISS
CARILLO. YOU MAY PROCEED THANK
YOU AGAIN MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AB FOURTEEN NINETY IS A
SIMPLE CLARIFYING BILL DESIGNED
TO ENSURE. THAT APPOINTEES TO
THE PRIVACY PROTECTION AGENCY
HAVE THE REQUISITE
UNDERSTANDING OF CONSUMER
RIGHTS. NECESSARY TO CARRY OUT
CONSUMER PRIVACY LAWS AS NOTED
IN THE- COMEDIAN ALICE'S THE
BILL WILL CREATE O ADDITIONAL
COSTS FOR THE STATE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINES
IS THERE ANY SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT OF OR OPPOSITION OF AB
FOURTEEN NINETY. THEY TO
POSITION TO AB FOURTEEN NINETY
PLEASE PRESS ONE NUMBER ZERO
USING YOUR PHONE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY. ZERO NO LINES IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU-
MISTER CHALLEN THANK YOU THAT
GETS OUT ON A B. ROAD ART
ADVOCATES OUT WITH REPUBLICANS
NOT VOTING THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
WE WILL MOVE ON NOW OLD MR
LEVINE. AB TEN R. FORTINO
THREE- AND I JUST WANT TO NOTE
THAT. WE HAVE A- SLOTS FOR
MISTER GRAY MIST- WHEN MR LOWE
AND MR MAHER CG. BUT IN THE
YEAR YOU MAY PERCENT FROM THERE
MR LEVINE IT'S AB FORTINO THREE
YOU HAVE A MOTION BY MISTER
BIGELOW A SECOND BY MISS
CARILLO. YOU MAY PROCEED THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS AB
FORTINO THREE AUTHORIZES THE
GOVERNOR OR LOCAL GOVERNMENT TO
DECLARE A STATE OF EMERGENCY.
FOR A LOCAL EMERGENCY DUE TO A
D. ENERGY STATION EVENT THERE
ARE NEGLIGIBLE COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH THIS BILL I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU- WILL GO TO THE
COLORS IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
TO AB FORTINO. THREE STATE YOUR
POSITION ON THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO
AGAIN THAT'S ONE AND THEN ZERO
FOR A. B. FOURTEEN ZERO THREE.
WHAT A LINE THIRTY SIX THREE
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. IN
MOURNING AT YOUR MEMBERS NICKEL
THE NATIONALISTIC BENDIGO GAS
AND ELECTRIC I RESPECTFULLY IN
OPPOSITION- AND WE DO OFFER TO
MEN MEANT THAT WOULD MOVE THE
LANGUAGE AND INTO A DIFFERENT
CODE SECTION THAT WOULD NOT
TRIGGER REGULATION THAT WOULD
SHIPPED HUNDREDS OF MILLION
DOLLARS ON TO NON IMPACTED
CUSTOMERS AND- WE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE THANK YOU. OKAY WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE THAT IS OUR ONLY
WITNESS FOR NOW ON ANYBODY
OPPOSED- MISTER STATE THEIR
NAME AND THEIR- ORGANIZATION IN
A POSITION THANK YOU. NINE
SEVENTY EIGHT SEVEN EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS ROB PURPOSE
OF IN CALIFORNIA EDISON WE HAVE
AN OPPOSE UNLESS POSITION- TO
AVOID UNINTENDED COSTS JUST
SNEAK OUT THAT THE BILL BE
AMENDED TO PREVENT TRIGGERING
BILL PROTECTION IN THE FORM
MAJOR DISASTERS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. I DON'T KNOW FOR THE
LINES INTO AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU- I SEE NO QUESTIONS WILL
BRING IT BACK MR LEVINE. THANK
YOU MADAM FIRST LAST FERNANDO
THAT GETS ADDED ON OR A ROLL
CALL WITH MISTER CALDERON
VOTING NOW MOVING ON TO MR
MERECE SU CHI AB TWO SEVENTY
NINE EVER MOTION BY MISTER
KALRA SECOND BY MISS CARILLO
YOU MAY PROCEED. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M
PRESENTING AB TWO TWO SEVEN
NINE ON BEHALF OF MYSELF AS
WELL AS JOIN AUTHOR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SANTIAGO TO PROTECT
SENIORS LIVING IN NURSING HOMES
AND INTERMEDIATE CARE
FACILITIES THERE ARE THOSE
COVERED NINETEEN PANDEMIC. AS
WE ALL KNOW SENIORS LIVING AND
NURSING HOMES HAVE BEEN AMONG
THE MOST VULNERABLE TO COVER
NINETEEN THIS BILL SEEKS TO
PROHIBIT. NURSING HOMES AND I
SEE APPS FROM EVICTING OR
TRANSFERRING. A CHANGE IN THE
CONDITIONS OF OPERATION FOR
RESIDENTS IN THESE NURSING
HOMES WITHOUT THEIR CONSENT OR
MEDICAL NECESSITY DURING THE
LIMITED PERIOD OF THE COVERED
STATE OF EMERGENCY PERIOD- WE
NEED TO PROTECT THESE
VULNERABLE SENIORS FROM BEING
CONVICTED. OR FROM SUFFERING A
TRANSFER TRAUMA DURING THIS
PANDEMIC IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL I HAVE MIKE DARK WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ADVOCATES FOR
NURSING HOME REFORM. AND DAVID
MALDONADO WITH SAVE OUR SENIORS
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT HANK YU
OPERATOR CAN GO THE WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO SEVENTY
NINE I THINK WE HAVE TO
WITNESSES ON THE WITNESSES LINE.
YES THANK YOU CHUCK GONZALEZ
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS MICHAEL CLARKE AND I'M
A STAFF ATTORNEY AT CALIFORNIA
ADVOCATES FOR NURSING HOME
REFORM. A NONPROFIT FOUNDED IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE TO
ADVOCATE FOR CALIFORNIANS LONG
TERM CARE. CANNER IS SPONSORING
AB TWO SEVEN NINE. EIGHTY TWO
SEVEN NINE PROVIDES AN
ESSENTIAL SAFETY NET FOR OUR
ELDERS LIVING IN NURSING HOMES
AND THE INTERMEDIATE CARE
FACILITIES. AND ALSO AT NO COST
TO THE STATE OR TO PROVIDERS OF
LONG TERM CARE. THE BILL THOSE
TWO THINGS FIRST IT TEMPORARILY
HALTS DEPICTIONS OF RESIDENTS
OF THESE FACILITIES BECAUSE
DURING THIS PERIOD OF COLD THE
BELATED VISITATION
RESTRICTIONS. IT IS NOT
POSSIBLE FOR RESIDENTS AND
THEIR FAMILIES TO ASSESS
APPROPRIATE NEW FACILITIES TO
MOVE TO. THIS IS TEMPORARY HALT
WILL COST THE STATE M. CONSOLE
IS NOTHING. INDEED IT MAY
TEMPORARILY SAY THE STATE
EXPENSES ASSOCIATED WITH
REVEALING CLOSURE PLANS AND
HEARING YOU FIX AN APPEALS.
SECOND THE BILL WOULD REQUIRE
THE FACILITY TO INFORM
RESIDENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES.
IF THE FACILITY ACCEPT THE
TRANSFER OF NEW RESIDENTS WITH
COLD IT. JUST REPORTING. SIMPLY
CREE A LAW ANIL. TO
REQUIREMENTS ALREADY SET OUT
AND FEDERAL REGULATIONS AND
CONSEQUENTLY NOT RESULT IN ANY
NEW COSTS. CANADA URGES THAT
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
SUPPORT THIS IMPORTANT BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WILL GO TO
THE WITH. I'M SURE REPEAT THE
NAME OF LINE. DAVE MY. I DON'T
BELIEVE THE BY UP TO TIME OKAY
WILL MOVE THEM I TO- SUPPORT-
OP TO A. TWO NINE. THE LATEST
TO PURSUE ON A TWO C. NINE
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOR BY THE-
AGAIN USING TELEPHONE PLEASE
PER ONE THEN THERE AT THIS.
WE'LL GO FIRST TO MIND THIRTY.
ONE THREE ONE THREE GO AHEAD.
GOOD NOW. MIGHT IS RUSS OKAY I
YOUR FORMER BOILS. SUPPORT
THANK YOU. NINE ONE TWENTY NINE
ONE TWO NINE. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS THIS IS
FORMER ASSEMBLYMEMBER AND
FORMER AS SOMEBODY AGING AND
LONG TERM CARE COMMITTEE
CHAIRWOMAN MARICO YAMADA IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU. WELL I. ONE THIRTY TWO ONE
THREE TWO. GOOD MORNING I'M DR
KENNETH TIGHE CHAIRMAN OF THE
CATO PACIFICA COMMUNITY
ADVISORY BOARD IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK YOU
AT THIS AT THIS TIME THERE NO
FOR THE LINES IN Q. THANK YOU
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
I SEE. NO QUESTIONS- WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE THEIR MISTER
SUITS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
IAGO THANK YOU THAT GETS OUT ON
A B. ROLL CALL. MR WHEN I SEE
YOU HAVE AB SEVEN FIFTY ONE AND
I BELIEVE YOU'RE PRESENTING FOR
MR LOW AS WELL BUT WE'LL START
WITH A B. SEVEN FIFTY ONE THAT
ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION. WE HAVE A
MOTION BY MISTER BIGELOW A
SECOND BY MISS CARILLO- THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND I'M ALSO A
PRESENTING AB TWO THREE SEVEN
MISTER GRAY. AB SEVEN FIVE ONE
WILL PERMANENTLY AUTHORIZED
COUNTY RECORDER'S TO ACCEPT A
LOT ELECTRONIC REQUEST TO
ACCESS CERTIFIED VITAL RECORDS
WHICH ARE BIRTH MARRIAGE AND
DEATH CERTIFICATES CURRENTLY
TWENTY FIVE COUNTIES USE REMOTE
IDENTITY PROOFING TO PROCESS
THESE I REQUEST IT IS
IMPERATIVE THAT WE MAINTAIN A
SAFE CONVENIENT- ACCESS TO
CERTIFIED VITAL RECORDS WHICH
ARE OFTEN REQUIRED TO OBTAIN
BENEFITS SERVICES OR INSURANCE
ON THE PHONE WITH ME TODAY IS A
REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE- COUNTY
RECORDER'S ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU- WE WILL
GO TO THE PHONE LINES FOR- MR
WYNN'S WITNESS ON AB SEVEN
FIFTY ONE. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR ROB GROWS CLOSER WITH THE
COUNTY RECORDER'S ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA- LIKE TO THANK
YOU AND YOUR COMMITTEE FOR
CONSIDERATION OF THE MEASURE
THANK AT THE MOMENT ARE ONE FOR
HER LEADERSHIP ON THIS WE ARE
IN SUPPORT OF THE ANNOUNCES
NOTED THE CARD IS NEGLIGIBLE
FOR OFFICES AND PROVIDING
ADDITIONAL CUSTOMER SERVICE
OPTION FOR THOSE ANY TO YOUR
COMMUNITY. AND HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU CAN EMAIL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WE'LL GO
AHEAD AND OPEN UP THE PHONE
LINES FOR PEOPLE WHO REGISTER
THEIR SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO
AB SEVEN FIFTY ONE. TAKE YOUR
POSITION ON AB SEVEN FIFTY ONE
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO AGAIN ONE ZERO FOR A. B.
SEVEN FIVE ONE. WELL THE FIRST
ALIGNED ONE TWENTY FOUR ONE TWO
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU FOR COMING WITH THE L. A.
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. NINE
FIFTY FIVE ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SURE MEMBER KEVIN AGAINST AS A
CORPSMAN KAISER ON BEHALF OF
THE ELECTRONIC FRONTIER
FOUNDATION AND PRIVACY RIGHTS
CLEARINGHOUSE IN A OPPOSE
POSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
BLAME THIRTY ONE THREE ONE.
GOOD MORNING LEE AND YOU CAN'T
GET OUT WE HAVE THE FACT THAT
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. WE HAVE LINE. ONE
THIRTY SIX ONE THREE SIX. GOOD
MORNING MODELING PLAN ON BEHALF
OF TAXI A IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. NO FURTHER LINES IN
Q. THANK YOU I SEE NO QUESTIONS
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE JUST A
AS IN ALICE THE STATE'S THE
FISCAL IMPACT IS NEGLIGIBLE AND
THANK YOU I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU MISTER
WHEN THAT GETS OUT AND IN A
ROLL CALL I BELIEVE YOU'RE ALSO.
I WITH MR FONG NOT VOTING I'M
SORRY. NOW YOU'RE VOTING FOR.
YEAH THAT'S WHAT I HAD AS ALL
RIGHT THANK IT'S NOT AN AREA
SORRY FOR THE CONFUSION WHAT WE
WANT TO RECORD THIS RIGHT BACK
IT'S OUT ON A ROLL CALL
EVERYBODY'S VOTING IRATE ARE
YOU ALSO ARE GOING TO PRESENT
MR LOWE'S FORT AB FOURTEEN
THIRTY TWO IT IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO UPDATE FINDINGS AND
DECLARATIONS RELATED TO ONE
TIME FUNDS AVAILABLE. TO THE
ONLINE COLLEGE THE NUMBER
STUDENTS SERVED IN THE NUMBER
OF CREDENTIALS ISSUED- IT
ENJOYED TO DO PASSED AS AMENDED
WE HAVE A MOTION BY. DR QUICK
THINKING AND A SECOND BY MISS
CARILLO. YOU MAY PROCEED ON
BEHALF OF MR LOW- THANK YOU AB
FOURTEEN THIRTY TWO WOULD
ELIMINATE CALIBRATE COLLEGES
SINCE ITS LAUNCH THE COLLEGE
HAS ISSUED JUST THIRTY FIVE
CREDENTIALS TO TWENTY NINE
STUDENTS AND ITS PROGRAMS ARE
DUPLICATIVE OF THOSE OFFERED AT
EXISTING COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
ACCORDING TO THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS THIS BILL COULD SAVE
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA EIGHTY
TWO MILLION AND ONE TIME
FUNDING. AND FIFTEEN MILLION
ANNUALLY WITH ME TODAY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS AS MICHAEL
YOUNG WITH THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS. ALL
RIGHT ON THE WITNESS PLAN WHICH
HAVE MICHAEL YOUNG WITH THE C.
F. T. BENJAMIN MIKE WE WITHOUT
BATTERY OF TEACHERS- WE AGREE
WITH YOUR ALISON THE COMMENT-
ARE YOU STATED WE'D BE. TYPE WE
BELIEVE THE BOTH GOING TO. STAY
THE STATE MONEY IN- SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. OPERATOR
THERE ANY OTHER INDIVIDUALS ON
THE EIGHT B. FOURTEEN THIRTY
TWO EITHER IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. STATE YOUR POSITION
ON AB FOURTEEN THIRTY TWO
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AGAIN ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO FOR
A. B. U. FOURTEEN THIRTY TWO.
WE'LL GO WE'LL GO TO LINE SIXTY
SIX ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ALL
RIGHT ALREADY INCLUDE MANY SUCH
I TEACH ESL AT AMERICAN RIVER
COLLEGE I ALSO- THERE AS AN
ALERT YEP YOU PRESIDENT FOR
AMERICAN RIVER COLLEGE I AM IN
STRONG. UPPORT FOR A BI.
FOURTEEN THIRTY TWO THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THERE ARE NO OTHER
LINES INTO AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU. I SEE NO QUESTIONS- WE
WILL GO AHEAD AND LET MR LOW
KNOW THAT HIS BILL GETS OUT ON
A ROLL CALL WITH MR FONG. NOT
VOTING. THAT TIME WE GOT IT
RIGHT. THANK YOU MISTER WHEN. I
DID NOT HAVE THAT. YEAH AFTER
DID HAVE IT I'M SORRY AB TWO
THIRTY SEVEN- ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION IT'S BY MISTER
GRAY PRESENTED BY MRS IRWIN. WE
HAVE A MOTION BY MISS CARILLO A
SECOND BITE DR QUIRK YOU MAY
PROCEED AB TWO THREE SEVEN
PROHIBITS PUBLIC EMPLOYERS FROM
TERMINATING THE HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE OF EMPLOYEES AND THEIR
DEPENDENTS DURING THE WORK
STOPPAGE THE BILL ALSO GRANTS
THE PUBLIC EMPLOYEE RELATIONS
BOARD JUST JURISDICTIONS OF
ENFORCE THE PROVISIONS OF THIS
BILL THERE IS NO REASON PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES SHOULD USE LOSE
THEIR- HEALTHCARE COVERAGE AND
THAT OF THEIR FAMILIES AS A
POINT OF LEVERAGE TO BREAK A
STRIKE THE BILL IS SUPPORTED BY
NUMEROUS LABOR PARTNERS
INCLUDING ASK ME CTA. TEAMSTERS
AND THE PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS. THANK YOU WE
WILL. GO TO THE PHONE LINES FOR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO AB.
TWO THIRTY SEVEN. TO STATE YOUR
POSITION ON A B. TWO TIRTY
SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO ON YOUR PHONE ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO FOR A. B. TWO THREE
SEVEN. WE'LL GO FIRST TO LINE
ONE TWENTY SIX ONE TWO SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
CRISTINA ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS CAN SUPPORT. NEXT
WE HAVE LINE THIRTY THREE ZERO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE JENNIFER MILEY
BUT THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
WE'LL GO TO LINE EIGHTY FIVE
EIGHT FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
COOPER WITH THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF STATE COUNTY AND
MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF A TWO THIRDS THAT.
WE HAVE ONE MORE LINE. LINE
TWENTY SIX TWO SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS L. GOT IT
DONE ON A MATERNITY UNIT AT UC
DAVIS MEDICAL CENTER AND I
SUPPORT AB TWO THREE SEVEN
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NO FURTHER
LINES IN Q. THANK YOU WILL
BRING THAT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. I SEE NO COMMENT
THAT GETS OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL
WITH MR FONG VOTING HI. THANK
YOU MISTER WINNER. FREE
LANGUAGE THE GAVEL NOW TO
PRESENT- AB FORTY. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR I BELIEVE YOU HAVE
YOUR BILL AB FORTY THE
POLITICAL REFORM ACT OF
NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR- IT HAS A
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION WE HAVE
MISSED CALDERON AND MISS KOREA-
SECONDING. THANK YOU AB FORTY
WOULD REQUIRE ADDITIONAL
DISCLOSURES TRANSLATE MAIL TO
HELP INCREASE TRANSPARENCY FOR
VOTERS ON COMMUNICATIONS THAT
ARE OFTEN DECEPTIVE AND
CONFUSING RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE. THAT WAS MY THE SHORT
THAT WAS A GREAT PRESENTATION I
LOVE IT- DO YOU HAVE ANY
WITNESSES THAT YOU HAVE IN THE
QUEUE. IF NOT WE'LL OPERATOR
WOULD YOU OPEN THE LINES FOR
POSITIONS OF SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU TO STATE
YOUR POSITION ON AB FORTY
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO AGAIN ONE UP THEN ZERO ON
YOUR PHONE FOR EIGHTY FOUR ZERO
FORTY. WE'LL GO TO LINE THIRTY
SEVEN THREE SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ALL RIGHT TO MAKE THEIR
OWN ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
OKAY YEAH THANK YOU FOR THE
MIND AND GET ON THE BALL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WE'LL BRING IT
BACK TO THE MEMBERS DOES ANYONE
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS I SEE NO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. THIS
BILL GETS OUT WITH REPUBLICANS
NOT VOTING THANK YOU WELL THEN
GO TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR
MADAM SECRETARY CAN YOU PLEASE
READ OUR- MISTER. SORRY YOU
PLEASE READ THE CONSENT
CALENDAR SORRY SORRY DATE. AB
THIRTEEN TWENTY OF OUR QUE HAN
AB SIX SEVEN FOUR BENNETT AB
EIGHT TO FOUR BENNETT AB EIGHT
SIX NINE BLOOM AB FOUR SIX TWO
CARILLO AB ONE ONE TWO CARILLO
AB TWO EIGHT THREE CHEN AB SIX
SIX THREE CHEN. AB ONE TWO TWO.
TO CHEN. AB FIVE THREE NINE
COOLEY ACR FORTY FIVE COOPER A.
B. SEVEN ONE EIGHT CUNNINGHAM
AB ELEVEN FORTY EIGHT DALY. AB
OR DIE AB THREE NINE EIGHT FONG
AB FOUR FOUR SEVEN GRAYSON AB
FIVE NINE NINE JONES SAWYER. AB
FORTINO NINE LEVINE AB FIVE
FOUR SIX MAIENSCHEIN. AB
FOURTEEN TWENTY SIX MATHIS A.
B. FOUR NINE FOUR MAYES SB SIX
OH THREE MCCARTY AB FOUR EIGHT
FOUR MEDINA AB SEVEN FOUR NINE
AS AERION. AB FOUR NINE TWO
PATTERSON AB ONE TWENTY SALAS
AB FIFTEEN TWENTY SEVENTEEN AB
THREE ONE NINE VARIAS AB TWO
THREE NINE VIA PURDUE- AB TEN
THIRTY ONE VP OF A DEAL- EIGHTY
FIVE TO SIX WOULD AB FOUR FOUR
FOUR COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT AND RETIREMENT. AB
SIXTY THREE COMMITTEE ON
AGRICULTURE AB FIFTEEN FORTY
ONE COMMITTEE ON INSURANCE AB
FIFTEEN SEVENTY COMMITTEE ON
NATURAL RESOURCES. THANK YOU
THE CONTENT COUNTER MOTION BY
MISTER BIGELOW SECOND BY MISS
CARILLO AND THAT GETS OUT ON IN
A ROLL CALL AT THIS TIME WE
WILL- LIST ALL THE BILLS THAT
HAVE BEEN MOVED TO THE SUSPENSE
FILE- MR. MR SECRETARY CAN YOU.
CHECK NEEDS. AB EIGHT FOUR
THREE AGUIAR-CURRY AB EIGHT
EIGHTY AGUIAR-CURRY ABC OR
SEVEN ARAMBULA AB THREE SEVEN
ZERO ARAMBULA AB SEVEN THREE
ONE HOUR CAN AB FIVE SIX THREE
BERMAN AB SEVEN SEVEN FIVE
BERMAN. AB ONE ONE SEVEN
BOERNER HORVATH AB THREE SIX A
BONTA AB FOUR EIGHT FOUR EIGHT
CALDERON AT FOUR SEVEN ZERO
CARILLO AB THREE ONE SIX COOPER
AB NINE TO FIVE- DOLLY AB TEN
FORTY SEVEN DALY. AB TEN NINETY
EIGHT DALY AB EIGHT SEVEN SIX
GABRIEL A. B. SIX FOUR FIVE
GALLAGHER. AB TWELVE SIXTY NINE
CRISTINA GARCIA AB FOUR NINETY
GIPSON AB TEN THIRTY EIGHT
GIPSON AB EIGHT EIGHT TWO GREAT
AB ELEVEN OH FOUR GRAYSON. AB
FIVE ONE TWO HOLDEN. AB SIX SIX
SEVEN IRWIN AB THIRTEEN THIRTY
ONE OR ONE AB TWO FIVE FOUR
JONES SAWYER AB THREE EIGHT
FOUR KALRA. SB SIX FIVE FIVE
KALRA AB FIVE SIX FIVE LACKEY
AB EIGHT TO NINE LEVINE AB FOUR
SEVEN ONE LOW. AB SEVEN EIGHT
NINE LOW EIGHTY FIVE FIVE FOUR
MATHIS AB TWENTY TWO MCCARTY A.
B. FOURTEEN SIXTY SIX MCCARTY
AB ONE OH ONE MEDINA AB TEN
FORTY MURATSUCHI. AB TEN EIGHTY
THREE IN THIS AREA AND AB
SEVENTY EIGHT OH DONALD AB TWO
SIX NINE PATTERSON AB SEVENTY
TWO PETRIE-NORRIS AB EIGHT FOUR
SEVEN QUIRK AB FOUR NINE EIGHT
QUICK SILVA. AB NINE FOUR FIVE
RAMOS AB SIX FIVE FOR RAY IS AB
ELEVEN THIRTY SIX THREE OF US
AB THIRTEEN THIRTY SIX SIXTY
THREE CITY THREE OF US. AB
SEVENTY THREE ROBERT RIVAS AB
TWO FIVE TWO ROBERT RIVAS. AB
THREE SIX FOUR RODRIGUEZAB SIX
ONE FIVE RODRIGUEZ AB TEN
SEVENTY ONE RODRIGUEZ AB THREE
SIX SIX BLANCA RUBIO. AB THREE
SEVEN EIGHT THREE SEVEN BLANCA
RUBIO AB TWO TWO ONE SANTIAGO
A. B. TEN TWENTY FOUR SANTIAGO
AB SEVEN ONE SEVEN STONE. AB
THREE NINE ONE VIA PRODU- A. B.
NINE THREE ONE VIA DO AB TWO
ONE EIGHT WARD AB TWO TO THREE
WARD AB THREE ONE ONE WARD AB
ELEVEN THIRTY WOULD. ONLY BE
ELEVEN THIRTY ONE WOULD AB TEN
TWELVE COMMITTEE ON
AGRICULTURE. AB FIFTEEN SEVENTY
FIVE COMMITTEE ON HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT. AB.
FIFTEEN SEVENTY SIX COMMITTEE
ON THE JUDICIARY. THANK YOU SO
THOSE WERE THE BILL'S WHERE
AUTHORS HAVE WAY PRESENTATION-
THEY WILL BE MOVED TO THE
SUSPENSE FILE TO BE DISPENSED
OF- IN THE THIRD WEEK OF MAY.
IF THERE IS ANYONE IN THE QUEUE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO REGISTER
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION THAT IS
ALL YOU CAN DO IS REGISTER
SUPPORTER OPPOSITION FOR ANY OF
THOSE BILLS THAT WERE LISTED ON
THE SUSPENSE COUNTER YOU MAY DO
SO NOW. YOU CAN GO TO THE PHONE
LINES MR. OPERATOR THANK YOU WE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO TO
STATE YOUR POSITION ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR THAT'S ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME
PLEASE. WE DO HAVE SEVERAL
LINES IN CUBA JUST A MOMENT
WHILE WE GATHER THOSE FLYING
NUMBERS. THANK YOU. WE'LL BEGIN
ONLINE THIRTY SEVEN THREE SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I AM HRE
TONY TO KERO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY TWO
MCCARTY AND AB FIVE SIX THREE
O'DONNELL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ALL THE BEST LINE FOURTEEN ONE
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
GREGORY KRAMER ON BEHALF OF
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT OF THE FOLLOWING
MEASURES EIGHTY TWO ONE FONSI
ARGO EIGHTY FOUR SEVENTY
CARILLO AB OR NINETY GIPSON SB
SIX FIVE FIVE KALRA AB EIGHT
NINE LEVINE AB TEN THIRTY EIGHT
GIPSON AND AB TEN NINETY THREE
THAT'S VERY AND AB ELEVEN
THIRTY WHAT. THANK YOU THANK
YOU. LINE. FIFTY FIVE ZERO.
CHEN MEMBERS CAN UNDERSTAND
SAYS WITH CORBIN AND PASTOR ON
BEHALF OF THE FOLLOWING CLIENT
ELECTRONIC FRONTIER FOUNDATION
AND PRIVACY RIGHTS
CLEARINGHOUSE IN THE OPPOSE
POSITION FOR AB ELEVEN THIRTY
ONE WED AND ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LOW INCOME CONSUMER
COALITION IN A SUPPORT POSITION
FOR A BI ELEVEN THIRTY SIX BY
THREE OF US THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. WINE ONE HUNDRED THIRTY
EIGHT ONE THREE EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS KARINA LEGO ON THE ON THE
HALF OF THE CHILD CARE
LAWCENTER AND OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY TWO MCCARTY THANK YOU.
THANK YOUNG. LINE ONE FIFTEEN
ONE ONE FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
OMINOUS THAT MEASURE- CLOUD OUT
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE
OF EDUCATION AND LEARN SUPPORT
OF AB 221852 DEGREES PUNCHING
AB FIVE NINE NINE FOUR OF
EIGHTY EIGHT TWENTY NINE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOUNG. LINE. ONE TEN
ONE ONE ZERO. YEAH LINE TEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN YOU MAY
PROCEED. IT WILL BE IN THE
GARDEN KEEPING EACH. LINE ONE
TENANT NEED YOUR OPEN NOW. SOME
OF ON LINE. ONE SIXTEEN ONE ONE
SIX. GOOD MORNING DAVID HAD TO
DO WITH A RP CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB ONE ONE
SEVEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
LINE. ONE TWENTY THREE ONE TWO
THREE. YOUR TO STEWART I AM IN
OPPOSITION AB TWENTY TWO CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY IN THE CHILD CARE
PROVIDER. THANK YOU. NINE ONE
OH ONE ONE HUNDRED ONE.
SUSANVILLE CALLING IN
OPPOSITION TO AB ONE OH ONE IN
AB ONE THREE SIX THREE THANK
YOU. NEXT WE HAVE LINE ONE
FORTY ONE FOUR ZERO. HI THIS IS
TONY ROAD DOLLARS WITH CAPITOL
RESOURCE INSTITUTE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB ONE OH ONE.
THANK YOU. FIND ONE FORTY FOUR
ONE FOUR FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
KOK WHERE THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF STATE COUNTY AND
MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF AB THREE SIXTY.
THANK YOU. NINE SIXTY SIX SIX
SIX SHOULD GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME
IS NAEEM A CHARLES CALLING ON
BEHALF OF CHILDREN COUNTY SAN
FRANCISCO AND THE SAN FRANCISCO
EARLY CARE AND EDUCATION
ADVOCACY COALITION- CALLING IN
OPPOSITION- AB TWENTY TWO.
THANK YOU. WELL I AM THIRTY
NINE THREE NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI GOOD MORNING THIS IS
DEVIN MURPHY CALLING ON BEHALF
OF THE ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
LEAGUE AND FOURTH THE PORT AB
SEVENTY TWO. THANK YOUNG X.
MEXICO LINE FIFTY TWO FIVE TWO.
YES THIS IS JEFF JOHNSON- PART
TIME TEACHER REPRESENTATIVE OF
THE SOUTHWESTERN COLLEGE
EDUCATION ASSOCIATION CALLING
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWELVE
SIXTY NINE. THANK YOU. LINE.
SIXTY SIX ZERO. RIGHT GIVE ME
HI I BRINKLEY MANY PERCENT AYE
TEACH ESL AT AMERICAN RIVER
COLLEGE ALSO AFFECTED UNIT
PRESIDENT THEIR INSTRUCTOR PLEX
FOR AB TWELVE SIXTY NINE GARCIA.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NINE ONE
NINETEEN ONE ONE NINE. HI MY
NAME IS PAT TOBIN AND THE
FAMILY CHILDCARE ASSEMBLY DISCO
WE AREN'T STRONG OPPOSITION TO
AB TWENTY TWO THANK YOU. LINE
ONE FORTY NINE ONE FOUR NINE.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS RON RAPP ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION- WE ARE PROUD CO
SPONSORS OF AB FOUR NINETY AND
EIGHTY SIX FIFTY FIVE THANK YOU
THANK YOUNG. LINE ONE FIFTY
THREE ONE FIVE THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MORNING MADAM CHAIR
NUMBER ONE NOTHING BURKE ON
BEHALF OF SEVERAL PLANTS THE
MORNING AFTER AB THREE SIX SIX-
THE CALIFORNIA NURSE MIDWIFE
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT. AB
THREE SIX EIGHT. FOR EXAMPLE
WITH THE PLANNING AND URBAN
RESEARCH ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. AB THREE NINETY ONE
CALIFORNIA BEEKEEPERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT AT
EIGHTY FOUR SEVENTY ONE- W. E.
P. WORLDWIDE ENVIRONMENTAL
PRODUCT IN SUPPORT. EIGHTY FOUR
NINETY THE BLACK LEADERSHIP
COUNCIL AND SUPPORT EIGHTY
EIGHT EIGHTY HAVE ATTACKED
HUMANITY CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
AND EIGHTY FOURTEEN SIXTY SIX-
BLACK LEADERSHIP COUNCIL AND
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. I AM SO
EIGHT SEVEN EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. OKAY I'M SORRY NINE SEVEN
EIGHT ARE YOU ONE YOU- WILL
MOVE TO LINE ONE FIFTY ONE ONE
FIVE ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
MARTHA CARRERA REPRESENTING THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWO TO ONE AND- YOUR AYE
VOTES FOR PASSAGE THANK YOU.
THANK YOUNG. LINE ONE EIGHTEEN
ONE ONE EIGHT. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS THE MAN MESROP IN THE
BERKELEY SCHOOL I RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE AB TWENTY TWO. THANK YOU.
PINE. SIXTY ONE SIX ONE. HI MY
NAME IS KELLY TRYING TO
CONCERNED PARENTS SEVEN
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG OPPOSITION
AB ONE OH ONE. THANK YOU NEXT
WE HAVE LINE NINETY SEVEN NINE
SEVEN. HELLO STE YES. IN THE
END SALAS CALLING CALIFORNIA
I'M LAWS. SO- SANTROL.
MEANWHILE THANK YOUNG. WELCOME.
ONE FIFTY SEVEN ONE FIVE SEVEN.
HELLO THAT MEANS THE CONCERN
SEVEN CALIFORNIAN AND AYE
OPPOSED AB ONE ZERO ONE. THANK
YOU. FIND ONE FIFTY TWO ONE
FIVE TWO. DIANNE RIFLE LETTER
FROM CHILD CARE PROVIDERS IN
BERKELEY CALIFORNIA WHERE BOTH.
EIGHTY TWENTY TWO. NEXT WE HAVE
LINE EIGHTY NINE EIGHT NINE. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON- CHERRY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THIS IS MARK
A WIN FROM SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
AND I'M CALLING IN OPPOSITION
TO AB ONE OH ONE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. YEAH WE HAVE LINE.
ONE FIFTY FOUR ONE FIVE FOUR.
HELLO MY NAME IS RANDY
LANCASTER AND READING OF THE
MEASURE CALIFORNIA AND THERE'S
A CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS I HOLES
COOKERY SERIES I AM OPPOSED TO
AB ONE ZERO ONE. THANK YOU NEXT
WE HAVE BLIND. ONE ONE THIRTY
SEVEN ONE THREE SEVEN. CAN YOU
HEAR ME. YES YES. OKAY I AM A
CONCERNED PARENT FROM NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA AB ONE OH ONE IS A
COMMUNISM HEARING WASHING
PROGRAM POSE ALL RIGHT LET'S
MAKE SURE WE'RE JUST GOING TO
SAY OUR TEAM ORGANIZATION ARE
POSITION PLEASE THANK YOU. MY
NINETY FIVE LINE NINE FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. ONE NINE FIVE IS
YOUR DEVICE ON ME. WE'LL GO TO
LINE. ONE SIXTY TWO ONE SIX
TWO. YES TO BRITAIN FROM STEP
ONE SCHOOL AND BERKELEY-
STRONGLY OPPOSED AB TWENTY TWO
AS CURRENTLY WRITTEN. THANK YOU.
QUIEN. ONE SIXTY THREE ONE SIX
THREE. HI THERE THIS IS DAVE
WITH CALIFORNIANS FOR QUALITY
EARLY LEARNING WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE AB TWENTY TWO. NEXT WE
HAVE LINED ONE SIXTY NINE ONE
SIX NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
THIS IS KATIE FROM OUR LONG
CALIFORNIA MY FAMILY OF THE
VICTIM- AND WE ARE STILL LONGER
FOR CHINESE CULTURAL
REVOLUTION. I AM STRONGLY
OPPOSED AB ONE ONE WHICH IS-
ANOTHER COCKTAIL POLLUTION
ANYWHERE THANK YOU. BOOK NINE
ONE SEVENTY TWO ONE SEVEN TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES GOOD
MORNING COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS MELINDA FOR THE L. I'M
THE OWNER AND OPERATOR OF
ADVENTURES IN LEARNING CHILD
CARE CENTERS IN ORANGE COUNTY
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB TWENTY
TWO. THANK YOUNG. NEXT WE HAVE
LINED. ONE SIXTY FIVE ONE SIX
FIVE. GOOD MORNING HOLD BY ONE
NOT SCHOOL DISTRICT WITH STRONG
THE PUBLIC. TO THANK YOU. WE
HAVE LINE ONE SIXTY ONE ONE SIX
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AT THIS
TIME THERE ARE NO FURTHR LINES
IN Q. WONDERFUL THANK YOU THAT
CONCLUDES OUR PUBLIC COMMENT-
AND CONCLUDES OUR
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
HEARING TODAY THANK YOU ALL.